Oh my God,
the evidence about mental,
the mental health crisis that adolescence,
when Greg and I wrote the article,
we were,
you know,
we saw lots of hints that depression and anxiety were gone way up and we think
that's related to the protection you have do.
Okay.
So let,
let's talk about that just for a sec and then go back to the book.
So I've got a dem potential demographic explanations for that in part.
Well,
and I don't know if you guys have looked into this or not.
Well there,
there's,
there's two things that I think might be contributing to it.
One is two or three things.
One is the average age at which children are,
uh,
the average age at which people have children has gone way up.
That's true.
Okay.
So why does that matter?
Well,
because I think people get more conservative and cautious as they get older,
but that's true.
But it's a very small effect.
Okay.
And it's,
wait a second.
Okay.
It's the having of the kids,
which is what makes them more conservative.
When you have kids,
you are more threat sensitive,
you're more likely to vote for the right wing party.
So just delaying child,
child,
uh,
childbirth wouldn't.
Okay.
What about,
what about fewer siblings?
That would,
yes,
that's part of it.
Uh,
and this is what we're seeing in Asia too.
When you have a lot of kids,
you're not quite as worried,
you don't have all your eggs in one basket.
Well and you can probably just worried and the siblings raise each other.
That's right.
Right.
And then there's a lot of
quite,
exactly.
It's the free play and the fighting,
the working things out for themselves.
Those are essential skills of adulthood.
Okay.
So cool.
So then all right.
Smaller family sizes,
part of it.
Well,
and then also what's happening increasingly in schools is that kids aren't
allowed free play and there are certain,
not even loud,
rough and tumble free play.
Exactly.
That's right.
That's one of the biggest things about,
so the two,
the,
there are three giant there.
There are a lot of cards.
It's,
it's,
I mean,
this is such actually,
it's really fun puzzle because it's like the biggest social science puzzle of
our age.
What is happening that's making so many of our systems go haywire and I'm
focusing on the university.
The big three I would say are one is the loss of,
of free,
unsupervised free play.
And Peter Gray has been brilliant on this season I Boston College,
showing how even among young animals,
they have to practice the skills for adulthood and getting in at showing that
to,
exactly.
So getting in conflicts and then dealing with it and sometimes losing your,
come back,
having game in which there's a problem,
but you have to work it out with the game stops.
That's what kids always did.
It's only recently the night beginning in the nineties that they're always
supervised because we're afraid if we take our eyes off them,
there'll be kidnapped.
And that was never a risk was never right.